[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been an innocent bystander watching
what was going on in the sec certainly
with alabama texas a m and then we
noticed that they were going to have
their meetings this isn't media day
these are just meetings down in florida
might as well be media day and uh we
thought we should have on mike rodak
mike worked he covered the nfl so he
covered belichick with the patriots and
he uh also covered the buffalo bills for
espn now he's covering alabama sports
for ale.com and he joins us now
uh mike what's the difference between
belichick and saban
ah there's a big difference i don't
think you can get very much out of
belichick i think for saban you're going
to get a lot i think if you ask the
question the wrong way he's going to
jump on you i think if you
um you know ask a question in a way that
sort of gets him going he's going to get
going with belichick it's just sort of
gruff and not a whole lot happening but
saban's going to tell you something he's
just going to you know there's going to
be a whole lot of theater with it i'm
wondering if you could feel it if it's
tangible that the sec commissioner greg
sankey kind of put the kibosh on
comments here uh encouraged uh coaches
you know lane kiffin wasn't allowed to
come on our show
is there a feeling at these meetings
that these coaches everybody's playing
nice and nobody's going to say anything
inflammatory
there is i don't think there is an
official decree that they can't talk
about you know the issue between nick
and jimbo and i think they have talked
about it to some extent but i think
there is sort of a
message set that whether it was explicit
or not from greg sankey that they needed
to sort of tone it down and make sure
that there was still some level of
professionalism as uh as lane kiffin
described but essentially he put it you
know you text somebody you might say a
little bit more in the text than you're
willing to say in person so in this case
they both said a little bit more when
they were alone in their own cities and
on camera in both cases but when they
actually saw each other in the same room
in lane's opinion they they weren't
willing to say quite as much and that
was really what sankey wanted he wanted
a meeting that was focused more on the
issues than sort of the back and forth
in the drama that's happened but saban
and fisher are in the same meeting rooms
they are they are so it's just the head
coaches that the 14 head coaches in the
sec there's a seating chart that got out
yesterday where jimbo's actually seated
with all the sec officials and greg
sankey and herb vinson and all those
guys and
and the initial opinion of that was okay
they wanted jimbo to be separate but in
reality it's just he's the chairman of
that group that rotates on a yearly
basis and uh there wasn't a as big of a
story there as it might have seemed
yesterday all right let's go back a
couple of weeks ago
how did this get out of hand considering
what saban was saying and who he was
saying in two
private event and a lot of times these
coaches don't realize that this does go
viral eventually you might be talking
it's a home court advantage and then all
of a sudden fisher
gets wind of this um
how would you describe that to somebody
who's still trying to understand exactly
what happened
right so i was actually there that night
in birmingham and it was a case of they
only thought that the media was going to
be there for 15 minutes that was the
initial um ruling that was given to us
and that was i think nick saban's
understanding which is why that question
about nil to this room was put at the
end of the speech thinking that the
media would be gone by then it wouldn't
be recorded on camera it wouldn't be a
story nobody ever kicked us out and so i
was there there was other reporters
there their tv cameras there we were 20
feet away from the stage like if he
didn't see four tv cameras 20 feet away
from him you know i i doubt that he
missed those but i don't think he
thought it was going to get out the way
it did i don't think there was some
grand plan here on nick saban's part to
make this a story uh but i think once it
became a story that nick saban saying
texas a m's buying his players it did
work into
his whole argument about nil that he
wants to get into the national
discussion which is the original purpose
of nil for players to make money off
marketing deals has been lost in that
now there are collectives and groups of
boosters who come together and buy the
rights to these players and it
essentially becomes pay for play where
recruits are being paid to come to
school and that is his overall point
i don't think it was part of some grand
plan and i think he almost looks better
more that the more that jimbo talks and
the more that jimbo seems like the more
emotional more emotionally charged guy
where nick saban seems a little bit more
grounded right now yeah you know saban
was it he didn't realize he was making
it personal
by saying that they bought all the
players bot is the key word if he just
said look they took advantage of a
window here a loophole
we need to do the same thing and it felt
like he was saying to these businessmen
hey we got a pony up we want to be the
number one recruiting class well if
you're jimbo
and he's already sensitive about the
recruits they get that you're buying
players then he goes scorched earth on
saban the person
and stuff going on behind the scenes and
i thought that i mean
i thought jimbo fisher looked worse out
of this because i don't think saban
meant what it sounded like but jimbo
fisher you can't i mean you know that he
meant what he meant when he said that
about uh nick saban exactly right it's
definitely it's a battle of semantics a
little bit because the way that nick
saban wanted it that texas a m bought
their players does accuse them of
directly paying their players which is
not really what he was trying to say he
was trying to say that there's
collectives of boosters that on the side
pay these players
which is legal the way that the rules
and the laws are written right now
that's perfectly fine and that's been
nick saban's point is that he's not
accusing them of doing something wrong
he's more accusing them of doing
something that would violate the spirit
of the rules and the spirit of what nil
is but when jimbo fisher comes out and
says there's an interview he did
separately with the san antonio tv
station where they asked him why are you
so good at nil and he says we're not i
don't know if anybody truly believes him
on that and i think the whole argument
that we don't know about nil we don't
know what collectives are
i don't know if anybody's truly buying
that and just to claim ignorance i agree
it does make him look worse in this
situation okay i give you two questions
for jimbo fisher he has to answer
what do you ask
well i think first of all he he threw
out a lot of accusations about nick
saban um and is what his former
assistants might know and we've asked a
few of them you know billy napier from
florida and kirby smart and they sort of
dodged a question they didn't say it one
way or the other but i think jimbo
fisher needs to sort of move forward
with that accusation or either pull it
back he's kind of stuck in the middle
right now where he's he's made very
vague accusations but hasn't really put
any um meat on them so that's one of the
questions and number two i think it's
just the idea of
are you truly claiming that these
collectives don't exist or you don't
know about these collectives you have no
knowledge of that i think again nobody
believes that and i think at some point
there needs to be an acknowledgement
that these things do exist and yes they
are legal underneath
the current framework and that's fine i
think if you're texas a m you want a
segment signal to the rest of college
football that you pay well
now you're doing these things that's
right i mean i don't think there's
anything wrong with that in the current
day and age but do you see where
the ends well i don't even know if the
ncaa can do this but let's say the sec
does greg sankey say to those coaches
or administrators
this is what we need to do
that that you know we have to have
guidelines with name image and likeness
would sanki approach i think
yeah i think they they can try but
ultimately and this is why greg sankey
went to capitol hill i mean it needs to
be something on a bigger scale than just
the sec the sec can't really make a rule
themselves that would carry water
legally which is the biggest problem
that's that there's anti-trust laws on a
federal level that led to these lawsuits
that led to the supreme court ruling
that if they try to make these
rules that are more restrictive and um
create some sort of guard rails as
everybody likes to say about nil they're
opening themselves up to a lawsuit and
there's very rich powerful people with
very rich powerful lawyers who will sue
the ncaa or the sec whoever it is and so
it needs to be done on a federal level
and that's been nick saban's message
that's been craig sankey's message and i
don't know if there's anything that they
can walk out of this week
with any new sort of nil rules or
legislation to fix this what's the end
game here for the sec
well i think long term if you're talking
5 10 15 years down the road i mean i
think it's a professional league
essentially where you have contracts and
there has been talk about that this week
where coaches want transparency they
want contracts they want an agreement
like there is in professional sports in
the nfl and essentially where players
are not just paid for nil and their name
image and likeness they're paid salaried
and it's more out in the open it's more
transparent as you know you can look up
anybody's contract in the nfl i think
coaches want to be able to look up and
see what players are making across
college football and i think that's
ultimately where the league will go is
where players are paid and it becomes
more of a a pro league that
players have the option to go to school
essentially which is what it's been all
along but it's more authentic to what
actually college football is right now
great stuff mike good to check in with
you and i hope you're having fun down
there
yeah it's in the basement of a hotel i
think there's a rumor that there's a
beach out there somewhere so i'll look
into it
thank you mike
you got it thank you that's mike rodak
he is uh covering alabama for uh a-l.com
the alabama media group there